les automobilistes ontariens qui ont
pris la route ce week-end ont peut être
remarqué une nouveauté à la pompe des
autocollants contre la taxe carbone
doivent désormais être installé sur
chaque distributeur d'essence
cette nouvelle offensive du gouvernement
fund ne plaît pas à tous les
propriétaires de stations-service
je suis contre l'idée d'être mise à
l'amendé si quelque chose arrive aux
autocollants indique-t-il des clients
pourraient par exemple décidé de les
retirer les stations-service prise en
faute recevront une amende de 500 $ pour
une première infraction et de 1000 $ en
cas de récidive
le premier ministre d'oxford a toujours
défendu ses autocollants
c'est une question de transparence selon
lui or ce que les autocollants du
gouvernement progressiste conservateur
ne précise pas c'est que la taxe sur le
carbone est accompagné d'une ristourne
du fédéral la population ça ne dit pas
grand chose on dit on ne dit pas les
pour et les contre lewiston taxe oui ça
va coûter plus cher même si je sais qu
on présente ça va coûter plus cher
d'ailleurs au cours du week-end
plusieurs automobilistes qui faisaient
le plein ne savais pas qu'une partie de
la taxe leur été redonnés à queen's park
le débat entourant ces autocollants a
été houleux le printemps dernier les
partis d'opposition notamment accusé doc
folle de dépenser l'argent des
contribuables pour de la propagande et
de la partisanerie même la fédération
canadienne de l'entreprise indépendante
qui se range généralement du côté des
progressistes conservateurs a dénoncé la
mesure le gouvernement fed a prévu
dépenser 30 millions $ pour se poser à
la taxe sur le carbone en plus des
autocollants dans les stations services
les progressistes-conservateurs ont
lancé au printemps une offensive
publicitaire mais leur bataille ne
s'arrête pas là ils ont choisi aussi
s'adresser à la cour suprême du canada
pour tenter de faire invalider la taxe
fédérale
et si mathieu simard a du canada toronto